Okay so where's the parallelism?
So one problem is F and this while loop.
Notice that we pull out vertices and
we put vertices back in.
The vertex that we just put in depends
on the vertex that we pulled out.
So that appears to create a sequential
bottle neck and since they while loop
executes O of V times, then the span
would appear to be O of V, as well.
This makes the average available
parallelism, essentially,
a constant plus
the ratio E divided by V.
So, is that good or bad?
In real life, graphs are sparse, and
so what that means, is that we should
expect the size of E to be O of V.
That means the average available
parallelism will be a constant and
that's definitely bad.
So this concept of sparsity
is a fact of life.
Think about a social network.
The vast majority of people will
have some maximum number of friends.
Let's say, I don't know 1000,
independent of how many
people are in the network.
Or imagine a worse case,
which might be a linear graph
that's shown on the right.
This might represent, oh, I don't know,
a bunch of hermaphroditic anti-social
worms who only associate with
their immediate offspring.
Anyway, since sparsity's a fact of life,
we're going to have to live with it and
therefore the sequential
algorithm is bad.